et sachez que ça a été un peu chaud
n'ont pas chômé on s'est beaucoup
rapproché non pas vous vous êtes dit des
monnaies on s'est dit les mots qui
sonnent ouais y'a pas eu papa dans maman
y'a pas de grand maman
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce-qui laquelle il a presque eu
parce que moi j'ai une photo à l'appui
non quand vous l'avez là dans mon
portable
non mais d'où vous avez une faucille et
vieux un petit câlin entre vous et à
quoi vous canine et 11 oui bah oui c'est
comme j'adore isabelle à partir de
calais ou fait ça il était tard j'avais
peu toute manette
voilà j'avoue je suis pour savoir la jsk
quelqu'un m'a envoyé une photo de vous
un travail maxime galy nom maxime c'est
qu'ils n'ont maxime gagner qu'est ce que
vous venez de lui dire je le dirai plus
tard non j'ai peur que c est moi je vous
le mettez dans l'émission l'a dit le
ba-ba pedro valence
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pedro pedro fait quelque chose allait à
merci et on était beaucoup avec grand
maman hier soir on a fini très tard
ensemble et on a essayé de retour garder
c'est vrai que j'ai passé une soirée
délicieuse un merci mais sans blague
j'ai passé une bonne soirée ben
heureusement samedi on a commandé des
pizzas
alors c'est ce qu'elle a fait parce
qu'en fait ce qui s'est passé je vous
raconte tout sourire
on a commandé des pizzas et amauri
j'aime beaucoup le travail avec nous a
commandé des pizzas et ce con il a mis
des anchois
donc qu'est ce qu'elle a fait est
l'arabe ou le lave et fromages et
anchois et elle a mangé toute maison
choix comme ça après moi je mangeais les
morceaux de pizza
on était comme ça oui c'était de prendre
comme ça non mais c'est vrai hyper
romantique un mois il réellement ginon
choix et moi je mange ce soir c'est
excitant même commis ou pas oui dès à
présent que t'étais pas là toi non il
veut pas il veut pas se brûler bravo
donc ne dit rien ou parce que vous ayez